good morning honest is now a chair of
the House Ways and Means Committee as
chair I find that due to the state of
emergency declared by the governor as
the result of the Cova 19 pandemic and
in accordance with the governor's
emergency order number 12 pursuant to
executive order 20 2004 this body is
authorized to me electronically system
now may chair of the House Ways and
Means Committee what is this I find oh
dear can we stop recording till we
figure out why we've got an echo a very
strange kind of echoes I recommend you
muting everybody except for that I
apologize
it was the YouTube recording it must
have been caught but I'll mute all
except to you right now represent now me
are you recording yes good morning I'm
Susan Elm a chair of the House Ways and
Means Committee as chair I find that due
to the state of emergency declared by
the governor as the result of the kovat
19 pandemic and in accordance with the
governor's emergency order number 12
pursuant to executive order 20 2004 this
public body is authorized to mean
electronically please note that there's
no physical location to observe and
listen contemporaneously to this meeting
which was authorized pursuant to the
governor's emergency order however in
accordance with the emergency order I am
confirmed confirming that we are eight
providing public access to the meeting
by telephone with additional access
possibilities by video or other
electronic means we have a utilizing
zone for this electronic meeting all
members of the
like legislative staff have the ability
to communicate contemporaneously during
this meeting through this platform and
the public has access to
contemporaneously listen and if
necessary participate in this meeting by
clicking on the following website
address HTTP / /ww join us / j / 9 2 6 1
3 0 3 6 5 3 2 or dialing one of the
following phone numbers 1 9 - 9 205 609
9 or 1 301 7 1 5 8 5 9 - we by providing
public notice of the necessary
information for accessing the meeting we
previously gave notice to the public of
the necessary information for assessing
this meaning including how to access the
meeting using zoom or telephonically
this information is printed in the house
calendar C providing a mechanism for the
public to alert the public body during
the meeting if there are problems with
access if anyone has a problem please
call to 7 1 3 6 0 0 or email H as in
house C is in committee s's and services
at LG dot state n H dot US D by turning
the meeting if the public is unable to
access the meeting in the event the
public is unable to access the meeting
the meeting will be adjourned and
rescheduled this is a revenue estimates
meeting the legislative revenue
estimates by addition that was developed
in the early 1970s are handled
differently from regular legislation
they end up as a house resolution which
never leaves the house usually the
resolution finishes each year dying on
the table but it forms the sense of the
house as to where the state's revenues
will end up and provides a measure of
how bad or good our revenues are
we need to cut spending or take other
preventative measures or have extra
money for new ideas growing needs or
savings when the Senate considers these
issues it usually starts from the House
estimates and they are inserted mostly
intact into budget bills as conditions
change the Ways and Means Committee
reconsiders the estimates puts up a new
pillow or it takes the old one off the
table amends it and then puts it back on
the table because of this sentence
scenario we do not start with a drafted
resolution today this is the second year
the first one died on the table
we start with prior year's revenues
agency or of course research economists
chambers of commerce and our own
personal experiences and training we've
been working on redoing the budget
estimates since the kovin shutdown began
as individuals in caucuses in small
groups and finally when able in public
session together today we will vote on
the final estimates for the fiscal year
that is ending and the one that begins
July 1 there is still considerable
unknowns about what June's revenues will
bring us and many more unknowns for the
coming year as a result most of our
estimates this time will be in ranges
our committee has a tradition of working
on these estimates bipartisanly and we
plan to maintain this this time as well
I want to introduce the staff that are
on the meeting assisting us
Christopher Shea deputy legislative
budget assistant and Jen for House
Committee researcher are the meeting
hosts additional LBA
and House committee services staff are
providing support relevant materials
have been posted on the main page of the
general court website under the heading
remote meetings please note that all
votes that are taken during this meeting
shall be done by roll call vote but
start the meeting by taking a roll call
attendance when each member states their
presence
please also state
there is anyone in the room with you
during this meeting which is required
under the right to know law represented
Malloy when you please call the roll
representative Ames we need to be able
to review representative Ames I see you
man I'm present in Geoffrey alone
representative Carrick I'm present in
Warner just my dog is with me but he's
sleeping
representative Southworth we're reaching
out to represent in Southworth because
we noticed that he had video but no
audio you may be in touch with Brad
right now if maybe we can come back to
him okay representative Malloy yes here
a law in my home
representative Schamberg present and in
wilmut and presently alone
I can see but I did not hear I was I
mean Randolph alone thank you there's
that if bunker present in Exeter by
myself being a Connecticut internet
connection is unstable again I suppose
they could be working on a power line
you're on in public view at the moment
okay not on my screen I am in Dover
alone thank you
I meant the audio represent of tomorrow
uh here in Swansea by myself
representing preface is absent
representative Lachman I said welcome in
his absence of Stringham I'm in Lincoln
by myself and I'm here
representative major I'm here by myself
in plasto representative Griffin I'm
here and wind him alone all the way I'm
see you but I did not hear an answer use
me
it looks like representative Lang
representative Lang I am traveling in
upstate New York and I am alone
representative you said President Salem
alone representative Edwards I'm in
Auburn and my wife will be moving in and
out of the room and background and two
dogs I'll keep them quiet represented
bursting I'm in beautiful Nottingham New
beautiful new action and the 118 I count
18 present two absent thank you and one
of us has fallen off again but well hope
that he gets back ok so we are going to
have a couple of changes from the way
we've been doing things before for those
of you who weren't here before we
started on this we are going to have to
do a vote on every single revenue option
that we that we consider on and decide
to take a vote on so it's going to take
quite some time probably to get through
some of these particularly the the
business taxes and the medicine rooms
tax which are fairly far apart and what
we'd like to do first is to take ten I
believe it's ten at this point revenues
and fill them in on the chart with a
split screen that Chris Shea will put up
one by one and then see if everybody is
willing to take a joint vote on those
and get them out of the way does anybody
have an objection to that procedure I
think it sounds highly well-organized
and I'm grateful for your efforts and
I'm sure representative majors - yes
representative nature and I though I
just realized this problem this morning
we discussed it a bit so so crochet
would you split the screen and put up
the revenue estimate sheet spreadsheet
and list off one by one and we can go to
those and fill them in okay you should
see it now mm-hmm so represent a major
would you like to start the filling in
of this perhaps set a major yes there
you are we'll start with the insurance
tax yes and the insurance tax take
agency estimates for FY 2020 which is
one thirty three point nine man follow
the high in the low and for twenty one
one twenty eight point two million for
the high end the logs could I interrupt
here
I'd like well maybe we should ask Chris
about this on there are certain taxes
where we agreed when we were discussing
this before
that we want to take the agency estimate
and the agency estimate is in this form
in rounded to the hundred thousands or
at least when we do it it's rounded to
the hundred thousands when it's over a
hundred
and it's not the agency estimate I would
like to see us rounding to a million
unless the whole revenue source is under
such as the beer taxes is under 50
million I don't know if everybody is is
in agreement with that the idea would be
to show this this is an estimate with
considerable questions to it but it
would change the final result someone
could I have a comment by Chris Shea on
what your you can provide whatever
estimates you would like represent
follow me so if you wanted round to the
insurance for instance excuse me the
yeah the insurance we're just talking if
you want to say 134 up 133 nine that's
the company's prerogative to do that yes
so typically in the past you have always
gone to the the 10th if there is a yes
you have
what's wrong with a 10th well when it's
the agency's estimate I guess that's a
better thing but if we're doing
something like saying we have a range
between five hundred and sixty-eight
point two million and seven hundred and
twenty point six million that seems a
little bit - okay I thought we were
discussing right now we are right now I
just wanted to bring that up early the
agency estimate with the the point will
why okay let me just do the insurance
tax again yeah well round to a hundred
and thirty three point nine it's both
high and low for the FY 2010 fight 21
one twenty eight point two a high in law
do you want me to continue our white so
Susan comes back I have a that has the
once we agreed on to know so why don't
we we just go back and and forth the
next one is the communication services
tax that's gene and the house estimate
is thirty nine point seven for the first
year high and low and and thirty eight
point eight million for the second year
high and low unless those any objections
will just continue yes Brahmi has his
hand raised I'm not sure if what what he
needs from a DUI mutant tell us what
your hands about rounding thing
so but some of these we are gonna have
Rangers correct yes okay yes these are
the ones that essentially with them
because the agency suggested them as
single numbers and and all of us seem to
think that the number was as reasonable
as as we were going to get they're
usually their taxes that are or revenue
sources that are usually pretty well
estimated by the agency can be estimated
easily by the agency I agree when we get
to fishing game and like we should
public a lot to decimals but that's just
my opinion
okay those revenues that were grand with
the agencies right and and none of these
have ranges and we want to do is discuss
them all at the same time like a
consensus the agenda salt the next one
Court starts and the communication tax
then I did the communication sticks and
you you do the courts okay the court
came in at twelve point three five I
would recommend twelve point four for
high and low range for fy2008 point zero
for the high-rent I mean the the low low
range for twenty one and nine point zero
for the high range but twenty one nine
point one would be the rounding okay
nine point one yeah yeah makes very
little difference but I think that nine
point one for the high range for FY
twenty-one
thank you and that leaves me to do
securities which would be forty three
they rounded themselves 43 for the low
and high range or twenty and 43 for the
low and high range for twenty-one on the
beer tax the high and low range for
twenty twelve point eight and the high
and low range for twenty one twelve
point nine yes and for other which is
the das revenues that they take care of
67.7 that's rounded on and low and high
range for twenty-one of sixty two point
seven and then to my skill to tobacco
settlement tobacco settlement well all
in high range of forty two point six in
the low and high range of 38.4 4fy 21 so
the first one was forty two point six
four twenty that flight point right
yes and 38.4 421 sorry about that
yeah it's easy to lose your place in
these things and utility property tax
41.8 low and high 4:20 and 41.9 low and
high 421 this statewide property tax
three hundred and sixty three point two
million
well the low and high 4:20 FY twenty and
three sixty three point one man the law
on high for FY twenty-one and Medicaid
recoveries 3.2 million low and high 4:20
and three million even for FY twenty-one
low and high now act like a consensus
calendar does does anyone have an
objection to leaving all of these things
on our little consensus calendar
don't see anybody raising their hand to
votes for the revenues for 20 and 21 on
insurance communication services Tax
Court's securities beer other tobacco
settlement utility property tax
statewide property tax and read
recoveries representative aims yes
I'm not hearing anything from
representative Carrick I'm not seeing
that side of Carrick did he get lost
again it looks like we might have lost
him let me check the attendees list and
make sure he's not there well we can
reach out to him yes please do that I
don't think we need to wait though okay
representatives Southworth represent
representative Southworth if you can
hear us you may need to respond to a
prompt on your screen is Brad already
well I'd represent Southworth to the
list because I'm asking him to unmute
and it he's no it's not happening
yes representative Malloy
yes representing Schamberg yes
representative Tucker yes was that a
bunker yes
representative Marlowe yes was any of
Griffith not he's not here representing
Lachman he's not here
representatives string him yes
representative major yes was any of
Griffon representative Griffin yeah
represent of all irate yes
did your language spawned representative
Lang I've not heard any I've not heard
anything
no not muted yes he's not muted when
he's represented Carrick yeah with an
ancient picture website carrot do you
vote yes or no on the euro cent thank
you okay thank you
representative Edwards yes
was there a bursting yes
representative I'm going to call on
could you call him represent laying
representative of all may yes we have 16
yes to absent and if I may just give you
an update we haven't been able to reach
representative Southworth if if you are
on if you could maybe raise your hand
and let us know that you can hear us
that would be helpful
otherwise with people what slangy I
stepped out take the internet dropped
out I'm a yes Thank You representative
Southworth you can't you tried his
number and he's not yeah we're gonna try
keep trying but we haven't gotten a
response
okay so the vote being 17 to zero our
consent calendar consisting of the
revenues for insurance communication
services tax court securities beer other
to echo settlement utility property
texts statewide property tax and
recoveries passes so now we will go on
to discuss the the business taxes and we
are it it sounds like were we're sort of
in we we are at least overlapping a fair
amount let's put it that way and what
we're going to have to do is suggest a
couple of alternatives and then discuss
them and then see if we want to add a
third or more or yet another alternative
and on vote on all of those in see if we
can get to a vote that has the majority
of the people present for one of them
and that and the one that has the most
votes it's somewhat like what we do with
our usual straw votes but it's going to
take longer so I would like to start out
by recommending a range for business
taxes for the year 20 and I think we
should do 20 and 21 separately on this
one
on the year twenty on of six hundred and
seventy eight million to seven hundred
and twenty-two million and we are using
rounding to the to the million mark
because we're talking about very large
amounts of money and huge amounts of
uncertainty so six hundred
seventy-eight low to 722 high and if you
can all note those down because we're we
I don't think Chris is going to want to
put in individual he doesn't have a
place to put in options so represented
major would you like to represent a
range 420 you're muted there you go okay
range 420 for the business taxes six
thirty six to seven 1600 right now I'm
looking at the six thirty six to seven
sixteen yes yes Epson balmy yes on the
shear screener you're able to see below
where I've added you arrange and rip
some majors range oh very good thank you
very much
everybody can see that right so where
could we I would like to have
representative Ames discuss the low and
reasons for the low and high on the
Democratic side and represent major can
can present or ask someone else to
present the reasons for low on and high
on
on the Republican side and see if we can
come up with a joint alternative names
yeah go ahead
okay I hadn't been anticipated being
called on in this manner but I'll do my
best so no that's fine so I want to
start by saying that we're dealing with
tremendous uncertainty and even even
though they're in fiscal year twenty
were really at the nearly at the end of
the year there's still uncertainty and
that uncertainty in the business taxes
derives in part from the novelty of the
Javad virus economic circumstances that
we're living through but also and
related is the decision by DRA who
allowed a deferral of payments from the
deadlines that had been in place in
April to mid June so a couple of month a
couple of weeks from now payments will
have come in that ordinarily would come
in in April and those payments will make
all the difference they will shed a lot
of light on this situation we're talking
about right now the FY 2013 said what we
know about business tax is historically
is that a big chunk of the in fact
almost all of the
payments in June the revenues that come
estimated payments on the expected tax
that will be due at the end of the year
these are called if we call them
estimates and the the it's almost as
maybe ninety five percent or perhaps
even a little higher than that sometimes
our estimates in this year so estimates
relate to at least in theory to the
expected tax liability for the current
year and so they are likely but not
necessarily to reflect covin however
many taxpayers in the ordinary course
pay estimates based on last year's tax
taxes and if that behavior continues
then over it doesn't really affect in a
significant way okay thank you Tom but
so so I guess what I want to get to is
that there's uncertainty and then the
other end there are it's uncertainty
related to estimates and the other point
is that given the deferral ad by by D
are a significant revenue is going to
come in this month that ordinarily would
come in in April we don't know how much
that is a lot of it will be related to
to payment of tax on activities that
occurred last year
DRA has estimated about forty eight
million dollars will come over and we
will receive in in June I have no
question - no no basis for questioning
that
number and so I think we're left with
with estimating how much of the usual
estimates will be paid in and Joan
perhaps also where we need to question
the 48 million dollars that the RAS
estimating would come over and perhaps
some taxpayers simply won't pay because
of the circumstances they're in so given
all that the the low range that that
that I'm talking about is its 678 636
I'm sorry no getting confused here 678
and that is essentially what DRA has
estimated that the low and we think
that's about as low as this going it
could possibly go so that's why we put
that in I'll be interested to hear what
the basis for the lower number of 636 is
in the other proposal on the high end
722 represents a assumption that all of
dr a's estimated revenue from april will
in fact four over into and be received
in june so the april revenues would be
we'd get an add-on of about 48 million
dollars and then the additional money
that we see coming in in in june would
be would represent estimates plus about
five million dollars i think or roughly
that
miscellaneous revenues from tax returns
and audits less less refunds and it
would reflect I think a reduction of the
usual estimates that we think we would
get by about fifteen percent so all of
that brings us down to the high number
that's in the Omni range of 722 that's
roughly the story and that represents
our my thought anyway on how this these
numbers might materialize thank you and
that's that yes fifteen percent that's
the way we were working it out yesterday
I do have representative streams hands
up hand up he was involved in reworking
yesterday and I'd like to recognize him
before I recognize represented Burstyn
who is also got his hand up okay thank
you I guess
adding to what representative Ames had
to say and adding and adding in my own
thoughts as well here is what we know
that we know we know what the numbers
delivered to date are that we've already
taken in about five hundred and seventy
three million dollars of business taxes
so if we have no money in June that's
where we'd end up
we know that many businesses are filing
later as representative instead and we
hope in June where originally they would
file in April we know that last year was
a good year for the New Hampshire
economy and likely for businesses we
know the business tax rates were reduced
you know that we've been running about
three percent under forecast before the
corona virus hits here's what we think
we know we know we have a number from
DRA of about 48 million that was
normally would have come in April that
is now expected in June and we think we
know that what the forecasted amount for
June would be for delay in filing had
not occurred and that number was
approximately 142 million so so that
those are some things to work with a
base assumptions what we don't know is
whether business filing the estimated
taxes that would come in in June and
take into account the impact of kovat or
they're just filing based on last year
and safe harbors we don't we some
businesses may file in July rather than
June that that would really mess us up
but to what degree the state will count
the live filing returns for this year's
even if they come after the end of the
year or something else so you know
basically when I look at 48 million and
then you know the normal 141 million
that people would file in June if things
were normal and we reduced that by about
20 percent
oh you know we're looking at even
numbers that are a little higher you
know I would say that's an optimistic
scenario that gets us to around 7 130
million in the high end and you know I I
don't see us with already at five
hundred and seventy three million I
don't see us collecting 63 million
dollars in June when normally we would
have collected a hundred and forty forty
two million plus we have the monies from
April being delayed I just don't see you
know kind of you know only getting 33
percent in the amount
that would seem to be you know a no
coronavirus estimate for this point so I
think the the the representative Army's
low-end numbers are are more realistic
meaning I think there's you know less
than a five percent chance the numbers
will come in below that amount and I
think there's you know a five percent
chance the numbers might even be above
730 million so I don't know if he need
me to go through the math a little bit
more but where 572 now we got one month
left and the two components are going to
be the gene estimated filings and the
annual returns that haven't been
submitted yet that come in June so that
was kind of the process and you know
when I boiled it down to we all boiled
thank you I just like to make sure we're
using the same numbers on Devanagari
case sent to us on Friday night which
was the their end of the month for the
month of May on a document on the
business tax analysis document says that
they and many with year-to-date 579
point five which is somewhat higher than
what you were using
thank you I have 573 so I appreciate
that that was where what we had before
but on maybe we should bring in briefly
from the audience I can't remember
whether Devin Devin is is in there and
Melissa Rollins is in there so that they
can confirm to us although
representative I'm here this is Devin
Roderick from Department of Revenue
yes thank you um when when I printed out
your NHD are a business tax analysis
sheet that you sent Friday night it said
that for the month of for the end of the
year FF YTD net if I'm reading that
correctly on this year we have five
hundred and seventy nine point five
million is that recessionary yes just so
you know Melissa Rawlins is also unmuted
she has her hand up okay so let us know
where she was if she had some
information for you as well so just as
you're asking your question right so
should I on ask her to come up first
she's available to speak yet her her
she's unmuted and she can respond now if
she would like okay okay okay yes sure
um the difference between two numbers
that you're speaking about one with the
neutral dr a business tax analysis that
Devon had sent down that number is just
a breakdown of document types but it
does not include adjustments adjustments
are typically bounced checks not
supplied payments seven number should be
using five seventy three million is
adjust Menemsha ideally business tax
analysis is gross deposits okay so we
should be using five seventy three point
points what point seven one seven thank
you
and that's the number from the FY 2010
are a daily cash revenue report that
sent along with the monthly
quartz on Friday okay it's good so this
is fugitivity adjustments that you
normally get bounced checks and
something else that I missed yeah I mean
miss apply payments mystified payments
that have to come out cut okay so so our
number is approximately six million
higher for the high end if we calculate
it the way we calculated it yesterday
which was to take the June 19 s Timofey
Minh which were 105.9 add 5% for all the
other money that comes in and out and
then take a 15% loss of estimate
payments in 2020 June bringing it down
to ninety four point five million and
which would give us a two in total of
142 point seven million and a high
estimate on which has to go down five
17 million point for on representative
streams estimate going up to 7:30 I'm
not quite sure how he got to that using
a twenty percent loss but on the 20
percent loss when I had calculated it
out as I recall was another three or
four million or something like that so
we on we want to L&D want to talk before
norm talks absent of bursting you know
yeah
representative majors before I make my
comments many myself already addressed
by representative string them but right
and Romney is put his hand up do you
want to and I I don't were being unmuted
from afar but looks like we have to keep
on hitting ourselves yes so my only
thought is you know your range you're
using the da's rain estimate basically
your low end of a range mind as well so
that's fun and now can come talk to this
uh discussion around the the large
companies you know just not paying and
taking the penalty then we have a
discussion about
whether or not when the audits done at
the end of the you know that their
adjustments what takes up revenue put it
where it should be and so that's kind of
low end that much that it was gonna be
that rosy but yeah one thing that hasn't
been mentioned and that is due to the
pandemic well most of your business is
out hurting you big businesses as well
as small business and what's keeping
them afloat be able to have cash and my
feeling is is they're going to hold on
to their cash as long as possible in
order to be able to survive this hasn't
been taking into account yet and that's
one of the factors that we're down to
the six thirty six I can easily and as
far as the panel take me that cash can
come from two ways one is not paying the
taxes that they had anticipated and
defer them as long as possible into
twenty-one or really scraping the barrel
for their credit carryover using the
credit carryover from right here they
used about 75% of the DQ and we're up to
about two hundred and seventy million
dollars so he did and 25% of of that is
about better than sixty million dollars
and if they use what they able to scrape
up their top of that thirty name they
will be doing that
and then that's in the basis of
contributing to our lower number thank
you Mon could we hear again from Melissa
about on the idea that the credit on
clarify for us exactly what the credit
carry-forward
is does it include business enterprise
tax payers that have not been paying
business profits tax but have a right to
credits for it if they do so what the
credit carryover is is it's taxpayers
who overpaid their tax liability in the
prior year so when a taxpayer either
pays their tax liability they can take
it in two ways they can use a request a
refund or they can have that money over
it so it's not those taxes just recently
to see how much of that is utilized
everywhere it was a pretty consistent
trend that about seventy five percent is
realized about six percent is refunded
maybe about 19 percent as sort of a
potential liability and of course that
can fluctuate each year slightly with
requests that's just one the need for
extra cash during the carryover possibly
no and the other is to defer the taxes
into 2021 if they deferred far enough
that this
why didn't they walk back into 2020 that
would be it deferrals till September yes
yes paying substantial penalties
interest at that point but their goal is
to stay alive yes so and you haven't
been talking about the net operating
loss which we have more difficulty with
still I believe with estimating how much
is out there 2021 that would seem to me
to be more likely to be used because
there must be some reason that these
businesses are not using that that final
19 percent each year unless they were
really worried about a recession hurting
things now yeah because six percent goes
back in refunds no I'm just saying
that it's there businesses can save up
to ten million dollars to be paying off
things you know we won't have good
reasons for our numbers they won't write
them right so in order to go forward I
think on the time that I think we both
kind of agree towards the eye in our
disagreement is on the Loewen yes and so
now is the time to the ocean yes
Tom Samberg has his hand up I don't know
if he is a question about what we're
talking about yes I do Madame chair
between what we've already heard and I
think norm has just brought it up is
there a middle point that we can come to
on the whole end here that's what he's
talking about doing one of the reasons
that we picked the low end as the the
agency's estimate is that it seemed to
us looking at the various
recommendations that they were being
really they are not used to giving us
single numbers they were used to giving
us ranges but I presume they were asked
by the governor for single numbers and
then they passed them on to us on and it
seemed to us that they were being risk
averse in those single numbers and
taking their low end I don't know if
they would be willing to talk about that
or not if Melissa would be want to say
anything about how they picked a single
number whether they were heading towards
the midpoint where they were heading
towards the bottom so that they wouldn't
have to later say oh it's less than that
um thank you for the question represent
Amy I think we just looked at a
completely different this year than we
typically did I think Commissioner step
had sort of alluded to this that there
are so many different scenarios that we
could have picked and we just sort of
tried to go and identify what we thought
would happen based on the data that we
had already received and looking at each
individual painting type by fiscal year
and that's how we got to the number
on either side of that number of course
we've never done it before so while the
truth is the best day that we have to
get to where we we got to thank you a
bottom number no I don't think we looked
at this is this was a risk averse bottom
number I think this is where we just
looked at this is where we thought they
would come in at yeah okay so let me try
a compromise here which would be it's
going to be quite a large range but I
think we were that the situation
probably requires it
can we rip salami you never have some
Tucker who has her hand up country I'm
you're apparently about to come up with
the number but I was gonna suggest 650
you can say ting out I was going to
recommend 650 as the number six five Oh
mm-hmm
as a compromise because lower number yes
and concerns we were spending so much
time on FY 20 when I think 21 is going
to be much more did almost 21 is we were
very close on 21 actually and I don't
know what the methodology is used on the
other side where we've had to develop
these and anyway that was my suggestions
yes so let's take 652 716 and see how
many people are willing to vote on that
represent major would you go along with
that just as a first effort or do you
want to try let's try one thing at a
time one thing at a time to try 650 to
716 sure alternative let's call it one
just in case although in 2020 a low of
yes I'm making a note on my sheet here
of that particular one because we're
gonna take I'll fill out a separate vote
sheet for each one of these proposals so
we'll have it documented yeah so for
alternative one that we've just talked
representative Southworth yes clerk
representative Tucker yes person
tentative bunker
representative major yes represented
Griffin yeah represent Valerie represent
all right yeah there we go
think we've lost Rick represent
interesting yes you have representative
representative Edwards yes I'm sending
thank you it looks like we can go with
that one the vote being 13 to 4 on will
go with 650 to 716 for the first year
the second year we have two ranges one I
am proposing from 582 656 and the other
on representing major is proposing from
574 to 653 observe almac did you give me
thank you I represent Brahmi has his
represent of a bra me your dude okay
how's that I very close on these I would
just say take the average of the high
and the low and call it a day this is a
very fun to project yes just quickly we
think things are going to come back with
this clothes on high and a low
so again my suggestion is take the
midpoint of both yes we essentially took
a little bit larger range than you did
but I think we each respected the
agency's attempt to estimate this as a
representative Eames has his hand up
ripp surnames have San Mames he may need
to respond to a prompt about muting yes
I'm sorry so yeah I just wanted to
support representative romney's
suggestion i think that's a reasonable
there we go yeah I think we're gonna be
pleasantly surprised in 21 a lot of
people have put if you take a look at
the savings accounts in their other
rates a lot of that stimulus money went
into savings so I think there we're
going to be pleasantly surprised but
I'll stick with what we have right there
okay I thought the stimulus money was
required to be spent actually they
didn't call it stimulus today they
called it survival represents to unmute
please Jerry all right the the the way
that a lot of the stimulus money works
especially for state tax it just things
like the PPE the for federal for federal
taxes the PPP money they receive is not
taxable but the expenditures that turn
it into a grant on largely on payroll
are still deductible from the income
however you know our best understanding
and without a change in the law is that
the the PP money they receive
we'll be taxable for state business
taxes even though it's not taxable or
federal income tax for the businesses so
they vote and and businesses that are
doing well like law firms that got some
PPP money or or certain other businesses
may have not seen much of a decline
I've actually still received PPP money
still had pretty much the same amount of
income in a similar amount of expenses
so they're actually gonna see a little
bit of a boost in their business income
or business profits tax purposes and
that'll be part of this second year of
the biennium calculation I mean it's not
true for everyone and there's obviously
a lot of businesses you know that are
severely bottom line hurt but a lot of
the stimulus money is not you know
purely offsetting new costs or lost
profits for the businesses and it may
actually fill in some some some of you
know overall the gap in in in lost
profit that we saw I mean I know I
couldn't give you a range but because
the way our business taxes are set up
you know that may buffer a little bit of
or a significant portion of the hit that
that we would have seen this year so so
when you talk about the stip whether the
following up on representative ovaries
comments I would have to say I agree I
agree with that sentiment you know maybe
you know using a slightly different
rationale
thank you we're talking about a hit of
about 70 million at the high end year to
year and the low end at this point and
70 million also I well a little bit
from year to year based on what happens
in 20 that we tax in 21 so does anyone
want to change the 577 to 655 for the
second year
on this basis or just represent a
represent how does he end up just went
dead
okay again represent bursting yeah I
interpreted Jordan's comments - I didn't
interpret it as the business sector was
saving I think an article came across my
newsfeed this week that the April
savings rate among consumers among the
taxpayer was 33 percent and that was a
record savings rate for any and I
interpreted Jordan's comment
representative all these comments to be
focusing on the consumer or the taxpayer
not he wasn't talking about the business
stimulus I think he was talking about
the 12 on your dollar check I don't know
if I agree with his point but I think
that was his point and maybe he could
get back on here to clarify that's it
thanks thank you represent all or do you
No and then rep says his you do oh yes
we do not fear us he ranked zebra but
now do you know yes absolutely
this is a pain yes um Allen was correct
I was referring to the $1200 savings in
the 33% rate and then once people are
allowed to get out and get around and
you start doing things I think will see
a boost in meals rooms and the business
taxes as well as the entire economy in
the entire society actually starts
getting active and starts going again in
and will come back with a bigger boom
than it has but again you know 70
million I don't know if we're gonna take
that big of a hit or not for the second
Tucker onion please yes I think we
should try a vote on the alternative one
I think at that point we're presented
this quite reasonable okay any other
comments then the clerk will call the
roll on business taxes FY 21 low of 577
okay there we go
this is for the vote on the vote of the
low of 577 million to the high of 655
million for FY 2021 representative aims
yes obscenity of Carrick yes presented
Southworth yes
clerk votes yes presenting Schamberg yes
exactly of Tucker yeah representing
bunker yes
representative gamar low speak up please
tentative major yes percent of Griffin
yeah representative O'Leary yes there's
the end of a bra me yes
representative Lang yes representative
representative all me yes
thank you
recommendation of 577 million for a low
number and six six six 55 for a high
number for business taxes in FY 21
passes and will get entered okay we also
have a considerable range for the meals
and rooms taxes on in the second year in
the first year what we are looking at on
on I am proposing a range of 321 to 323
this tax is mostly in at this point and
we have the prep send major on right now
yes for the 2020 we're going to stick
with the agency's number three 18.6 26
then for the second year we have a law
of 320 point two got into that one yet
okay all right so so the I'm trying to
remember here the agency estimate I
believe is three 18.6 and they revised
part way through our process they
revised it I think was just at the just
before the weekend they revised it to
318 six yes and before that they were at
321 to 323 rather they were at 320 2.3
or something like that I forget so could
perhaps we listen to
Melissa Rawlins talk to us about why
representative Ali their vision was just
to to an adjustment to the formula I'm
looking at a presentation we have done
an adjustment to the months based on the
code of 19 as well as an economic
yeah the economic adjustment that's what
the reduction in the 3 million was was
reducing the economic adjustment which
was how plan was coming in without an
effect of code 19 we need in June what
we expect to get in June you're taking
the entire economic adjustment as I
understand it off the month of June and
I understand why that makes sense in
terms of chewing up on the the business
taxes because they're putting in two
estimates at the same time in and doing
a lot of them and they're chewing up
what they did the prior year in their
reporting but taking it off of June when
we've already got all the rest of the
money in the bank seems seems a strange
it's it's a 0.8% adjustment for the
economic adjustment of the fiscal year
twenty so the revenue had floating
thought there might be an adjustment
that might come down a little bit more
compared to how plan was so I think
Commissioner step had spoke about how we
originally did the plan as if there was
no covin 19 happening so we made any
adjustments that we thought would just
typically happen if we were doing the
estimate adjustment presentation to you
guys at this point and that would have
been a 0.8% which is the 3 million down
for June and then we looked at what the
adjustment would have been for June
which I think we had a 56% adjustment
which was about the 17 million which was
a reduction of three had anticipated
so again I think you have some wiggle
room you know as the 321 to the 318 and
I think we will be comfortable with a
number somewhere in there between 318
and 321 yep ok 73083 million dollars
that we were we were talking about yes
but it seems to me you're taking the
entire economic adjustment for the year
that we've already experienced 11 months
of the year and putting it into the
final month and and these taxes are
collected monthly on the basis of
reality rather than in terms of
estimates
that I I still think for June we would
have thought without code of nineteen
that we would have fallen below plan yes
by 0.8 percent in June not what
disregarding the kovat 19 but the Cohen
19 is already shown up in May which was
the April numbers which were full coding
so I didn't think I'm sorry I misspoke
but the 3 million was spread out when we
get our revenue estimates for May June
and they came in you can feel free to
adjust that if you don't think that's
correct
we're fine with that yeah well how many
people are willing to go with you said
318 but you'd said before or 3 18.6
which rounds up to 319 but we could
leave it at 3 18.6 are willing to go
with that as the low number and 321 is
the high number of ami reps fo Brahmi
has his hand up on represented but
Brahmi as well as major reps and agents
yes I see no point to mid point even
though we don't have a range at 1.4 man
apart which is a percent yeah at some
320 oh there was a major way in nature
webs on earth Romney correct why don't
we just what the difference it's not
would be less than a percent now yes can
we can we do it arranged then would you
for this the first answer for the
differences of tool and I would propose
we go to 3:21 period without a range
right no worries okay any comments on
that
I've got no hands up so we are talking
about fairly small differences at this
point so so we have that as a
possibility for twenty and twenty-one we
have a much wider difference why don't
we blow it on twenty okay so if there
are is no further discussion on twenty
and the clerk will call the roll on
Nelson Rose fiscal year twenty at 321
million
okay thank you
this is for the rooms and meals tax
estimate for 2020 at 321 represented
aims yes
representing Carrick yes
I'm Senate of Southworth I need to be
unmuted okay yes
clerk votes yes percentage Hamburg
yes I'm sanity of Tucker yes substantive
representative Stringham yes presented
representative Griffin yeah was that of
all are--
representative Doucet yes because they
have had words yes
representative Burstein yes cuz then
Evol me yes
oh is 17 yes 0 no and 1 not voting thank
you the vote for is in rooms FY 20 and
321 million passes we will proceed to 21
now the Democrats on this took the
agency number and went down considerably
the Republican caucus took the agency
number and went up considerably so you
really do need to discuss this
I'm putting as a start on low of tuna
259 million to a high of 323 million
represent a major law of 320 point to a
so would you like to start or someone on
may that you indicate on the Republican
metric seems to have disappeared for a
well I oh here comes Patrick Romney on
you you got muted again immediately but
we'd like you to explain how the
Republicans decided to go up from the
the agency estimate on twenty three
million dollars for the second year for
Nielsen ropes thank you again and I
guess in our discussion that the hotel
although with restrictions sure how
those restrictions for our status gets
enforced but the hotels can open up and
have probably some natural certain
people it's gonna take a while for that
to work through in terms of people
having confidence to to partake but
shots are open partially now I mean with
the outdoors and we have a
representative lang
who who was on me we open committee was
very vocal about thinking that we we see
the restaurants going indoor sooner than
we think maybe a 50% initially but you
know so so we factor all that in up to
80 percent of the this revenue was from
restaurants and I guess that's why we
had tomorrow optimistic view that that
could have may go up a little quicker
than perhaps your caucus felt it would
that's pretty much it thank you and in
our caucus we were looking at all of the
restaurants and lodging places that
we've heard of that are have closed and
aren't opening again and thinking that
it's going to be difficult to once that
is actually happened to replace them and
it's going to take take at least a year
if we're lucky before we get back to as
many restaurants and and rooms as we had
before so that's why we went down a lot
I cannot remember how we decided on that
particular number at this point if
perhaps I'm Tucker would you like to
speak
yeah I've certainly been in touch with a
number of people around it and people
are just not going to keep their summer
plans the Lancaster fair isn't going to
read open all kinds of activities
Jericho State Park all of these things
which are ordinarily draw people from
out of state and down state up here
anyway are canceled and I think it's
going to be a long time before people
see that they can stay in a hotel eat
out after all rooms and meals is mostly
meals so drawing people into the state
to eat out is a huge factor furthermore
I see that people are going to be
cautious about spending their money I
can't remember which one of our my
colleagues talked about the number of
people who had saved their checks that
came for stimulus and I think that
cautiousness
is a natural reaction probably a good
reaction to adversity so I I think being
over optimistic is not a good idea I
jump in Susan yes bro me and then okay
our new point is 54 million below no
plan dude the plan that we did during
the budget cycle so we were getting to
know some returns on them but we also
know that and I think we're starting to
recognize this I can't speak for the
government obviously but my assumption
he sees aware that the longer we wait to
die which means the more likely more of
them going to go are going to go out of
business so I just saw that out what
yes thank you
the I kind of agree with the comments I
was just gonna throw in the Highland
Games which is the biggest weekend here
in Lincoln in Woodstock area the entire
year it's that's in late September
it's the biggest Scottish games in the
country is postponed for this year so
they've canceled it for this year I
should say so
you know I do see some fairly
significant draws to the area being
reduced so you know the midpoint should
at least be fifty million below what our
estimate was before I would say we also
in places like Manchester are possibly
certainly this summer Lebanon and
Hanover area we've got on a lot of
businesses are getting very used to zoom
meetings instead of sending people
across the country very few people for
quite a while they're going to be
wanting to get on the plane and the
airlines industries are are pretty
desperate about that right now
and and that means that the business
travel is is going to be down as in
places that don't normally see real
tourists I don't consider going to tour
Dartmouth College as being tourism but
some people do and and that's another
factor that isn't isn't just the areas
that depend on these major events that
the rest of us really value and try to
go to so on we've got three hands up now
represent in Ames and then represent
Burstein and then
Raavi represent of aims okay I think
another reason for the low estimate from
the Democrats hasn't been mentioned
maybe maybe I missed it but the it
relates to the possibility some would
say probability out there wrong that the
there will be a resurgence of the virus
and if that occurs then the gradual
opening of the sources of the meals and
rum stacks that I think it's certainly a
premise of the DAR dra estimate will be
reversed sort of inevitably maybe we're
better at managing an epidemic now but I
think there will be a reversal and it's
it's it's not a question of optimism or
pessimism in my judgment it's a question
of looking at the possibility of a
reversal here and and anticipating that
you know low estimate that's part of a
low high set of estimates and in terms
of dealing with our state budget I think
it's it's important that that the
decision-makers factored into their
decision making the possibility that
revenues will be significantly down
because of the virus resurgence that
could have happened so that's my comment
thank you they seem to be pretty sure
that we'll have at least some resurgence
when the fluid flu epidemic starts just
not encouraging but on represent
bursting Thank You Jeremy really
interesting discussion and a lot of you
bring up some really valid points well I
am let's call it marginally optimistic
about next year
I think the prudent thing to do is to
err on the side of caution and if
there's a proposal to to drop the low
range I'm willing to deviate
significantly from the Republican low
range that's all I have to say thank you
rip said it but Brahmi wants to talk
again
I'm asking representative about me to
Thank You chair be careful this could
put up our about your Susan your
estimate your the Democratic caucus in
the Republican caucus highs and lows oh
yeah he hasn't put them up se and this
could could you put up the the LME highs
and lows you're not seeing that right
now no we aren't
hold on a second you know yes thank you
so again the midpoint to midpoint of the
ranges were we're 42 way in and change
defense on the range and that's
something we should discuss but alone
speak and then and then we can stop
number I guess okay on rape centered
nature probably should have been in this
from the start and he's back now I'd
like to take him next
and they'd member said Edwards this tack
rooms and males tax is one of the most
volatile that we have to deal with and
it's an immediate tax whereas the
interest whereas the business tax is a
delayed tax yes the sense is extremely
volatile its its volatile to if we have
a resurgent is volatile
if we have a vaccine none of us know
these things are gonna happen my feeling
is is probably is and so no matter who
we are we're not gonna get it right I
wouldn't have any problem of raising our
estimates because they're just as well
there as what we have now if I look at
all estimates we get saved your lowers
our high essentially right how low was
320 and your low was 259 that's a that's
a 61 million dollar spread right problem
raising hours by 31 million dollars
raising it yeah your lowest iment I'm
sorry
going the other way so lowering at 31
million dollars you said which would
bring us to - 89 - 89 89 - 89 and on the
other end we're not that's why our part
and we were 23 million a placing in a
point and no problem
changing 12 because of the volatility
and then the possibility of a vaccine
not only one resurgence but our number
of researchers so so I would raise or
3:34 yes yes in practical terms there
doesn't seem to be any way that we could
have a vaccine out to the public until
at least the fourth quarter Oh next year
I tend to agree with that but there's
everybody and various countries they're
racing to do it but I kind of agree what
you're saying yeah well scientifically
you can't do the tests you need in less
time and they're doing them now and if
people don't see safety apparently half
the population won't even get vaccinated
which isn't enough to reduce the fear
factors and the epidemics well that's
what I throw out to 89 334 well would
someone from on I see that
representative Edwards took his hand
yeah I just I want to say that I think
that moving as represented major I
suggested this is a very reasonable way
to first all to go the there's just
tremendous uncertainty out there and
it's impossible
truly it's it's truly impossible to know
which direction this is going to go and
we all hope that it will move you know
move to and a resurgence of the economy
rather than the virus but but that's a
hope so I think moving the way suggested
keeps keeps a pretty broad range which
reflects the uncertainties and it's also
a range that starts in its high point at
a lower level than we've been at
traditionally because of what all that's
happened and and so it's all great very
any further discussion of this I don't
see any hands so we'll have the clerk
call the roll on this alternative for
males and rooms FY 21 arranged from a
okay this is rooms and meals tax
estimate 20 21 289 to 334 representative
Eames
yes thank Eric yes
yes yes
clerk votes yes represent a Schamberg
yes
representative Tucker
yes representative bunker
substantive Stringham yes from Zenit of
major yes
representative ah Larry he's on mute
I'm standing to set yes
instead of Edwards yes presentative
representative Ami
yes well it is 18 yes 0 no one not
voting okay
vote being 18 to 0 on the motion for the
second year the meals and rooms tags at
289 million to 334 million passes now
we've only got one two three four five
six six is complicated Skyway fund and
seven which is not complicated votes on
tax sources revenue sources left do they
are closer together than what we've been
talking about it mostly do people want
to take a lunch break now or go further
for a while it's noon
yeah break break could we take a half
hour break then it means we'll be a
little late oh I forgot we've got it
might be kind to DRA if we tried to get
through three it's it's three more
revenues before lunch so that they can
that's tobacco I and D and rent and we
are pretty close to each other on those
it's just a matter of
big the ranges usually yes original bra
me and Edwards have their hands up okay
perhaps it brought me reps enema bra me
yeah I'm fine what's going to the three
and then we start every great if we
start at one o'clock
can we can we hear the two bills because
there's going to be a lot of people on
the phone it's listening to that and the
revenues can we do it that way well the
problem is that this revenue sheet has
to go to OLS and be processed and ready
for the calendar what would that work I
think that would be fine have enough
time to get the resolution done it's
it's in pretty good shape but just these
uh these numbers today right great
okay so we will do it that way
we will stop well another administrative
question to Jennifer on if when you do
it this way am I going to have to read
that whole document again when we go
back to revenue instruments afterwards
oh I'm not I'm not completely sure quite
possibly yes since you're gonna be well
I can leave out that party about what
the revenue estimates are about so yeah
you it'll go quicker we have to do a
separate one for the exact session yeah
okay so that's clear we can we'll do
these three taxes we'll take a break for
half an hour
we'll come back probably at one o'clock
it sounds like on and we'll do the exact
session and then we'll resume the rest
of the revenue estimates
so the first one is to Rome you still
have reps of major and Tucker with their
Oh they've just added them represent a
major yes representative Edwards has had
his hands up on number of times yes and
then he took them down again each time
okay Edwards did you want to say
something
every time I've been ready to say
something the person immediately before
me said enough of it that you didn't
need to hear me so let thank you let's
knock out these budget estimates and
break till one right Tucker you're a
beauty you could have a shorter lunch
period fifteen minutes 20 minutes we
don't need a half hour yes well we'll
see where we are when we finish these
three so tobacco taxes in two and twenty
we we essentially agreed with each other
i committee caucus looked at the the
agency estimate and went did a range
from 206 to 207 which is around it it's
essentially the same thing on I would
like to propose that we just do 207 fine
fine and then but then in the second
year the agency estimate is 201 point -
you took that we took it but then we
went up to 212 and we have
considerations that take it down and
take it up the ones that take it down
are that people will know that there are
worse health risks from kovat if they
are smoking
and that more people will not have money
for the cigarettes the ones that take it
up are what was pointed out to us by a
lobbyists before Tove it happened on
that Massachusetts is banning menthol
cigarettes as of June and that won't
come into play for a couple of months
probably because the vendors will have
stocked up on menthol cigarettes before
it happens
and it is its impact is reduced by the
fact that a lot of the people who will
come up to New Hampshire to buy menthol
cigarettes
are people who are already coming up to
New Hampshire because the cigarettes are
cheaper and then the other one which is
important to me is that on people are
under an enormous amount of stress and
this will continue until we've got a lot
of people vaccinated from the cove even
if they don't have it and people who are
have been severely addicted to tobacco
that managed to get off of it
are going to be going back because of
that stress it's not a very fortunate
thing to think about when when we're
looking at our tobacco sales but that's
part of it so we went from a range from
201 to 212 and I'd like to know on a
Republican what the Republicans think of
those arguments why don't we take care
of 2020 first you suggest 207 yeah well
the thing is if it takes a long time to
do one of these roles I was thinking if
we could combine them after we reached a
all right John can we do that or we can
so Republican thoughts on mental stress
I assume took that into consideration I
am here this is a little bit of unknown
territory for us when it comes to the
cross-border sales in the menthols
we did we did attend a hearing where we
heard one of the association's about the
massachusetts banning menthols june
first we're really keeping an eye on it
at this point
we are still under the impression that
plan is a good number I think you have
some good points about numbers dropping
off but then being offset by other
numbers and that's sort of where where
we landed at we already have a lot of
cross-border sales that occur based on
our tobacco stamps being cheaper than
Massachusetts I also know there's been
proposed legislation to sort of remove
that band off and menthol for
Massachusetts so I think at this point
we're comfortable with the plan number
and only time sort of can tell if it's
gonna increase or not at that point also
within plan there is a little bit of
wiggle room because I do believe there
was a 5.4 5.7 excuse me addition in the
surplus statement item two e-cigarettes
as well so they're sort of have been
under
forming at this point compared to where
we thought so I think there's a little
bit of wiggle room within that number to
sort of scoop up those menthol
cigarettes as well yes sorry major yes
right now
messy too people are coming in droves
buy cigarettes in New Hampshire because
I think you're saving better than ten
thousand ten dollars a carton and
probably the same people that are buying
menthol now I'm buying them in New
Hampshire already I don't think yes that
I mentioned that counter factor that's
another factor I hadn't realized this
but apparently a very large number of
the the addicted smokers that use
menthol cigarettes are female but this
is a women's issue I believe it also
includes African Americans those from
what I've heard that I haven't heard
that one recently and our African
American population is one of our
smaller ethnic groups representative of
Brahmi and Devon Rodrigue have handsome
okay
um could we listen to Devon Rica first
oh one thing I just wanted to add is
that on our monthly report for tobacco
we do include char on the bottom right
that compares our effective rates to
other states and also speak to the
health risks
there has been a lot of I've been
watching all the news articles and
releases and there has been a lot of
public outreach pointing to the risks of
smoking you know given crow virus
there's also a lot of data coming out
that's so far that hasn't had an effect
on sales in profits so the publicity
isn't working which frankly I've had
severe tobacco addiction in my family in
it it's it's really hard to stop and
representative AB Romney and then any
Democrats that would like to say
something because we're the ones that
are the problem here I mean the 11
million difference is pretty significant
I mean that's all that's just that's a
big jump yes if you want a cup as I
could say a man and to have arranged to
a one - maybe - OH - OH - or two or
three or two - oh what a half or
something like that yeah I mean that's
having a change mate maybe the
compromise that they want to do we can
use as our tool one is the low end and
then a million or two onto it yeah
thanks yeah I think good points have
been made both sides I think that I'm
certainly ready to come down from the
Democrats high thinking that the menthol
effect is unknown it's sort of a new
idea and may be countered by the fact
that many people who buy menthol buy in
New Hampshire already wouldn't be much
add there
and I do wonder about the effect of
covet and the the I guess there are two
sides to that represent Omni has talked
about the stress factor leading to more
smoking but the other side of that most
certainly is the the relationship of
Cogan to the lungs and they're through
that - cigarette smoking and I think
that relationship has been there made
very public and is well known and I
representative Tucker said around an
hour send an article at least to me this
morning from Vermont and they're quite
optimistic in their efforts to reduce
smoking and in part it relates to this
kovat factor so given all of that and
given the uncertainty place and I'm
quite willing to go down represent of
our me Brahmi suggested a compromise and
I was thinking about that about two Oh
forums and sort of a place where would
come down to I think I could probably
live with that I'd like to hear from
others though okay Tucker do all four
sounds like a reasonable compromise to
me I'll go with that
okay I I don't like it but I will go
with it also I've done too many highly
addicted people who died on me okay so
too little for 2 and 1/2 204 as a range
in the revelry has sister Paradis
finally yeah I did wait till I get
unmuted yeah the the tool for it I think
I agree with you
representative all me that it's going to
be too low if any indication of what's
happening here in Hudson at Walmart and
the market basket and at the state line
the stores with parking lots filled with
Massachusetts cars I don't think there's
going to be any decrease in sales it's
not going to reflect on people in New
Hampshire buying cigarettes it's uh it's
going to be out-of-state people coming
up because of the ridiculous taxes
immediately to ours house
that's just my observations there's no
objectiveness to it it's very subjective
to be sure but when you've got people
pulling up to a half noise gas station
for the sole purpose of getting
cigarettes and buying lottery tickets it
seems to indicate that somebody screwed
up and trying to tack something out of
existence gonna hurt Massachusetts
substantially I do believe I have two
cents thank you thank you
anybody else I'd love to take it to 205
but I'm not going to mess up the console
nice okay wasn't arranged for 207
million for tobacco FY 20 and a range of
201 to 204 million for FY 21 and the
thank you for the 2020 number 207
million and for the 2021 number is a
range of 201 to 204 million
representative aims yes
representative Carrick yes
representative Southworth hmm we lost
clerk votes yes
representative Schamberg yes
representative Tucker yes
representative bunker yes Zenica Marlo
yes
representative stringer yes
representative major yes presented
Griffin yes
representative O'Leary yes
representative Rami
yes there's native languages set yes zan
of edwards you know representative
Burstein
thank you yes was any of all me yes vote
is 17 yes 0 no and 1 not voting
thank you the vote beings 17 to 0 the
motion for tobacco taxes at 207 million
in 2020 in FY 22 a range of 201 low to
204 high in 2020 in FY 21 passes and I
hope it will be on the chart shortly
here we come right so the next one on
that that is DRA is interest in
dividends tax you think we'd be far off
Democratic range my proposed range is
108 to 118 million in 2020 and the
represent majors is 109 that is one oh
eight point eight to thirteen eleven to
one thirteen point three so and then in
2021 we both made a range around the
agency's recommendation on the
Democratic range is 85 to a hundred and
five 10/10 in either direction and the
Republican range is five in
action so maybe for 2021 we could just
compromise on a range of seven in either
direction that would be 100 and and too
high and AD no 92 low no what am i doing
in d8 low on in 20 we've got we
essentially agree on the low number
either 108 or a hundred and eight point
eight and the Republicans are lower by
four point seven million in their
highest would represent all me Brahmi
yes so you do what you mentioned about
seven each way whatever
[Music]
but you finished about there the
calculations as well yes well when he
talks I believe about a fair amount of
these things in Ind that that we believe
that the reductions for next January to
June 21 the second half of the fiscal
year on would would reduce to only 10%
at that point and I think believe that's
how we got our higher number I don't
know if anyone on our side wants to
discuss that one at this point but that
that the business is in general do a
very good job of sustaining their
shareholders and that when they can
afford to they they from what I've been
reading they actually are already
cutting salaries in order to keep
shareholder payments up as revealed in a
so yes there anybody that represented
for brought me so well only that if you
go to the midpoint of those two ranges
were where two million dollars apart it
arranged with so a little different but
man I yeah - man apart at the midpoints
so if if we take your range and and it
by a million interests and that's
you mean my range and a high I'm just
you shift it over
we got a compromise or I guess another
way of increasing we're two million
dollars apart I'm trying to get it to be
1 million dollars apart so you can
either lower your range by a million you
know
107 to 115 or you can take our or as an
increase it by what a nine point eight
to one fourteen point three and then
basically you know so I guess I'd
recommend that way I won't touch yours
I'd recommend if you do the math you'll
find it that that's in range and one
higher but you've also gone up higher on
the low end and no higher than either of
us was then go do the other way then we
can do one away point eight and
had to lay into a high end that would be
115 15 what about that way that's fine
yeah the effect will be that we have
come up different points by increasing
it that way by 2 million it's going to
increase basically on our midpoint by so
one point one oh eight point eight two
one fifteen point three it makes our
Andy we've got lots of hands now
Tom Shambo represent chamber yes to
Madame Sarah didn't hear one word that
representative of Romney said you didn't
representative chamber can you hear me
oh dear it looks like his sound is gone
[Music]
okay offer is 108 point eight two one
fifteen point three okay Thank You
representative Ames
I think I'm unmuted am I see more good
yeah I think representative Brahimi and
about where where I was going to suggest
that's nice and I would just round up go
to 109 to 115 okay rounding on these
estimates that we really don't have a
good idea on when we can to represent
verb Romney is agreeing so 109 to 115 on
represent Tucker yes I think that's a
great compromise and I like the rounding
I think okay thank you
I represent a major agree well we have a
a vote possibility here the clerk will
call the roll on interest and dividends
in FY 21:09 too high of 115 million and
in interest and dividends FY 21 low of
88 too high of 102 million no no no 92
92 going between our two ranges and 92
would take us considerably lower than 88
this is for estimates 109 to 115 for
2020 and 88 million to 1/2 million for
2021 huh representative Ames oh yes
Carrick yes
Southworth oh no yes
clerk oh yes perhaps and of Schamberg
yes
representative Tucker yes no no banca
representatives string him yes it was in
a major yes it's in of Griffin yes
representative O'Leary yes then of a bra
me yes representative Lang represented
de set
yes does any of Edwards
yes there's no net Burstein yes was any
of all me yes oh is 17 yes 0 no one not
voting on the interest and dividends
estimates thank you on the vote being 17
to see me the motion for interest and
dividends FY 2109 too high of 115 and
interest and dividends FY 21 low of 90
of 88 high of 102 passes and we are at
our last tax of the morning it's not
morning but which is the real estate
transfer tax
and again we are pretty close in FY 2007
major takes the the agency estimate of
150 4.2 on we rounded that but we took
the on 105 154 as the low and gave a
little wiggle room up because we see a
considerable amount of activity still
there in the in the places with major
housing needs and I there was an article
in my paper about it yesterday actually
talking about the whole state as well in
the Realtors Association statements so
we went from 154 to a high in this year
of 156 it's not very much money this
year and next year we seem to be closer
to know I'm the lower closer so that's
for 2020 in FY 21 on we take a low of
135 going up to 155 as the Realtors get
better at the virtual showings and it
and the technology spreads further in
the state found a and representing major
takes one hundred and thirty five point
seven to a hundred and forty nine point
two the agency estimate was one hundred
and thirty five point seven so we all
are are thinking that it might be better
than the agency is thinking so maybe we
ought to start represent major do you
want
to say something before we asked the
agency yes okay we're not that far apart
so what I would recommend that for FY
2008 greed or 155mm and FY 21 we agree
to a spread of 135 - 150 - 135 - 150 -
right okay
is is there further discussion on this
one
or are we we all willing to compromise
on them
okay well we'll have the on the clerk
call the roll on real estate transfer
tax FY 20 155 million and FY 21 they
range from 135 million low to 152
okay thank you
this is the vote for real estate
transfer tax best estimate of 155 for
2020 and a range of 135 to 152 for 2021
representative aims yes
represent of Carrick yes none of
Southworth yes clerk vote yes Hamburg
yes then Dave Tucker yes there's any
bunker yes
representative demarlo yes
representatives Stringham yes is that a
major yes zennith Griffin yeah yes
Ronnie yes
presented Lane representative descent
yes
examine Edwards yes representative
Burstein yes there was any of all me yes
vote is 17 yes 0 no one not voting thank
you
the vote being 17 to 0 the motion for
real estate transfer tax passes with 155
million for FY 21:35 to 152 million for
FY 21 and it's being we don't have the
back home yes we do it the tobacco
Leonard yes we've got all of that there
so on when we come back from lunch we're
going to do the executive session first
on it's 20 minutes to 1 do people need a
nobody objecting to 20 minutes just
trying to start it one okay
we'll start at one with the executive
session and then we will go back we have
at this point
one two three four tax groups one of
which we agreed on completely so that's
the fishing game so everyone enjoy your
break Thanks if you guys haven't already
just mute yourselves and turn off your